I today have for you a disgusting new height
of narcissism.
Twelve hundred dollars stimulus checks are
potentially being delayed because the narcissist
in chief, Donald Trump, wanted his signature
printed on all of the checks.
So it looks like he's sending you the money.
People are waiting for those twelve hundred
dollar stimulus payments.
Some people have already gotten them via direct
deposit.
People who the first batch was people who
filed taxes already electronically for tax
year 2018 or 2019.
They were the first to start getting twelve
hundred dollar direct deposits.
Some people are now waiting on direct deposits.
But then there's another group and it's a
group that's disproportionately under-banked.
They may either not have access to a bank
account, they may or may not have regular
access to the Internet to actually get set
up with direct deposit.
So they are waiting for a paper check.
Arguably, those are the people who most desperately
need the money and it's possible they are
now going to be delayed because as The Washington
Post reports, the Treasury Department has
ordered the IRS to print Donald Trump's name
on the stimulus checks.
A last minute change which could delay payments
to millions and millions of Americans.
Now the Treasury is saying, well, we're not
so sure that it's actually going to cause
a delay.
They're denying that.
That's definitely the way that it's going
to go.
It could cause checks to be delayed several
days or longer.
According to senior treasury officials.
So a couple different things.
Number one, this has never happened before.
Never in history has a president's name ever
appeared on an IRS disbursement.
Now, the Treasury Department told the president,
you can't be the one signing the checks.
Trump wanted to be the one signing the checks.
But Trump doesn't have signing authority for
funds coming from the Treasury or IRS.
Why?
Because Trump is not formally.
He's simply not on the list.
You know, if I have a business, I have to
tell the bank who is allowed to sign checks
for my business.
Trump the president is not allowed to sign
checks from the Treasury or IRS.
So what they're doing is instead of Trump
signing the checks.
It's so pathetic how triggered this guy is
by not having his name on everything.
They're putting his name in the memo because
he can't sign the check.
So instead, his name is going in the memo.
At first, Trump was insisting he has to sign
them.
He was told it's just not going to happen.
So now this is what they're doing.
If Trump is going to be signing anything related
to what's going on right now, it would make
more sense for him to sign the death certificates
of people tragically dying from Corona virus
than for him to be signing stimulus checks
because it's not his money.
It's really our money.
And in reality, he should be signing nothing.
And we would all be better off if he wasn't
even involved in the Corona virus response.
But that's another story which you are probably
very familiar with at this point in time.
Chad.
Hooper is the national president of an organization
for IRS managers.
Chad Hooper says this is an abuse of government
resources.
Is anybody shocked by this, though?
From day one, Trump has been abusing and misusing
government resources for his own personal
benefit.
It's not Trump's money.
This has never been done before.
Trump is used to putting his name on a building
and he wants it on the checks.
And it is ego maniacal nonsense to the Nth
Degree.
And that doesn't change or stop because we're
in a pandemic.
This is Donald Trump.
And the other factor of this is this says
a lot about what Donald Trump thinks about
the electorate.
Donald Trump thinks the electorate is so gullible
and that voters are so shallow that maybe
they see Trump's name on the check and they
decide, I'm going to go and vote for him.
And I wish I was able to tell you, obviously,
that won't work.
But Trump won in 2016.
So clearly, these types of cheap bamboozling
tactics, these cheap, shallow tactics, they
do work on many voters.
And that's the saddest thing of all.
Did your cash, your Trump checks, well, then
stop complaining about him.
It's going to work on some voters and it makes
it all the more urgent that we remove this
malignancy in November.
After the break.
I'm going to talk about Barack Obama's endorsement
of Joe Biden.
I'm going to talk about Bernie Sanders escalating
his claims that it is irresponsible not to
vote for Biden in November.
That's Bernie who's saying that?
All of that coming up after the break.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
The Urban Gardening Corona Virus Quarantine
Project is growing by the day.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman to
follow the exciting adventures